welcome to this video yeah we're in the
middle in some blitz game off some blitz
game yeah I'm Nakamura again playing
some five-minute blitz you enjoy the
cubit sing videos a lot I gather from
the from the common some another one of
these oh yeah is playing some Italian I
am here but black and has some snatch
the pond but in the process Black has
weakened in some King side a bit with g5
still I'm black bloc has got prettier
good pieces of the bishop on b7 and the
knight on d4 in particular so um like
shouldn't shouldn't be too bad oh this
is a nice tactical trick if the pawn
takes on a three Bishop f3s close to
mate so white would use the Queen but
there are other things happening here
Bishop age seven for example I'm not
sure really what I would white should do
okay you went for this and now it took
the Queen now this is a funny position
again you cannot cannot take on on a
three because of this almost made and
very tricky position for wide rooty to
root tea to look so like the the normal
move but maybe white can take on d2 and
grab c5 and this looks this must be good
for black hat I'm not quite sure how but
it looks it looks really am overwhelming
get the some maybe threatens our
discoveries with the rook the I'd look
so I don't know I don't know what what
white should play here no the good you
can just move the bishop if you okay
maybe there's something better but black
could always just play a bishop deform
and then just maybe play c5c for I mean
just slowly making progress white cannot
do much really it's really a dominating
dominating position that black has set
up what should you do can you almost
never can take our three because of meat
and I don't see em I don't see what what
you can do in terms of getting active
I look so maybe I cannot move the night
because the rookies singing yeah I was a
girl kind of thinking about this maybe
it is working I very nice King g2 yeah
kingi 292 check king h 2 nite f1 mate
this is cute yeah it was over rook takes
g2 and I know knock out showing the line
that I mentioned yeah this was cutee
group takes g2
now he's showing some other line this is
also made probably yeah 9h for maybe
yeah King King h3 is made and this is
also made yeah I don't need to show the
line he's doing it for us this is fun
yeah very well-positioned minor pieces
can whip it can lead to funny checkmates
this is this is clear alright I hope he
continues to play a couple of games it's
certainly entertaining to watch but
Thomas sometimes it's take something
take some time to get a new game um
started young does it look like a new
game coming I could try to challenge him
but probably this is useless probably
it's got some some kind of formula
working I can I just declined so no
formula
yeah i've i've got also very young or
not very bad but relatively i'm bad
rating in in normal blitz so yeah that's
not much happening maybe he's got a
challenge out for ford pool but them for
another five minute game but he's got
much fun drawing arrows that's not me
that's like I'm we're playing our
drawing arrows yeah he's having fun with
this position okay a new game thankful
for that it's a fun to look at this but
it was very overwhelming for black okay
I'm some sideline here they caught the
virus off opening maybe transposing gap
with transpose to the French now the
French might catch some variation with
eat XD 5e 45 is done and the main move
he takes d5 isn't played so often until
this is this is the normal way to to
proceed like normally M goes form a long
castle CM Queen chief is a very direct
move I think there are lines where black
must sacrifice some pawn on the King
side so I'm not completely sure but
think that there are lines like that so
allowing Queen g7 and Queen takes h7 for
example well I plate Queen a5 and their
form white plate Kingda to to protect
the c3 porn so what will also suffer
from problems with the skin if you
imagine that black maybe play something
like yeah exactly b6 Bishop somewhere be
seven or eight six probably be seven and
then play for long castles and c5 then
White's king is in danger I think black
gum has a very good position here rook
takes you for now and I can we are just
playing playing too quickly I mean it it
isn't a good position anyway maybe you
should invest a couple of a couple of
seconds at least so black cam one this
pawn and still has hasn't a Tekkit it's
not even that the widest material up
it's just it just bad here you should
basics may be threatening Bishop takes
yeah this is this a bit slow but why not
Bishop a6 intending to take be three and
a two can you freeze look it's not clear
to me run to the hills or something yeah
now you can take on d3 and a2 I mean
this is easy ok black is also playing
too quickly I mean I am notoriously slow
sometimes at x games but if you smell
that there's a direct Wynette it really
smells like black has a direct when you
should at least invade invest like 10 or
two
15 seconds to to kill it I mean if black
would take on d3 instead of take a 2 why
just resins and there's no coming back
from that just it's just over here it's
still dangerous but why give up a pawn
and so on i mean this sir can easily
swing back to to white yeah probably
need to go back win win somewhere and
just I don't know this isn't clear to me
White's king is so I'm yep it in danger
but this F 3g for its it's fairly solid
and the night on e5 simply keeps the
position together and so it's really
really messy blacks got a cone up I mean
this is this is good but it isn't it
isn't clear at all
it should be good for black I mean but
it's not easy to play now Quincy one is
probably just a checker King be too and
you you don't really gain anything there
are 95 for some 95 97 was was one point
yeah whoo create maybe he can get group
d 8 in somehow but I don't I don't see
how ok is attacking d for now and f4
sorry greedy foyer was a logical way to
cover it's not easy to improve the rock
on on g8 is not doing so much
yeah what has it has an easy plan just
push Jeep G&H born yeah well black has
one extra porn but it's simply not
relevant I mean it simply doesn't matter
if there's an extra pawn the position if
why would have a pawn on b2 for example
and the equal material then why it would
be clearly better with his dominant
night and in this position wyatt earp
probably has compensation for the pawn
and okay 11 point is of course Black is
got 30 seconds left yeah black will lose
that on time yes he simply needed needed
to spend a bit of time when he had the
winning position the problem against I
cameras if you get two weeks two pawns
he will win on time it's simply not
enough very often and if you are really
in such a big advantage with an attack
coming you need to really kill instantly
unless unless you don't have you need to
take your chances when you when you have
them and now he will just you would just
win on time and now on c7 yeah this also
looks very dangerous for black get the g
porn also but like I'm where I added 50
seconds to the clock yeah I sometimes
does that too I don't know humiliate
people you can add clock time due to
your opponent and of course wide whites
winning now i am the jeep on is too much
yeah the problem was I mean maybe I can
at least put it on the board here here
like it just takes must take on d3 I
cannot I cannot put it on the board take
t3 takes and Queen a2 and g2 falls over
very very easy but you played in
somebody Queen a 2 ok next game on adds
a really good opponent cheer for now
camera this is a Grand Master dashi
kieran right hmm from from India here's
the two thousand seven hundred grand
master or slightly below to 680 or
something um here we have some Queens
pawn opening kind of a trumpet oh poor
ski ramp or ski or taller or something
like that but very off beat with 92 92
but it's a fairly normal position white
them has set up something like if you
were stretch on yeah this looks good for
what probably t5 this weekend he also
with queer with Bishop a for check
prevented castles and now what should
like do if you take on f3 Queen f3 looks
terrible yeah this looks ah very
dangerous for black queen e r3 maybe
queena 393 is also not bad threatening
95 yeah white has got everything in play
the bishop on b3 and the knight on c3
print put pressure on d5 and exactly
this is the problem if black takes on e4
now then f7 get some gets taken d takes
e4 9525 rogue f7 and white will win
maybe there's even something better
again now why Justin tends to take on d5
with the night with a clear upon
at the center at the attack good so um
this looks bad yeah it's three terrible
yeah probably just night XD 5 this is a
simple continuation yeah and maybe
there's something better always so as
possible the only thing what's difficult
to have at least it would be for me to
determine the best move now cameras are
playing quickly now it takes you four
maybe this is possible term probably it
is
no this looks like a real painful
experience for black where is he going
now give the Queen er yeah just queen
somewhere Queen g3 Quincy three years
good also textin c7 um night so Queen D
for you can just grab c7 yeah probably
queeny's have num night h16 age 6 is
that direct when it looks terrible for
black but not sure if you can win
directly here yeah this is so the idea
is taking on eric weiner for then
there's queen age 6 check and this is an
enormous threat now queen of energy 5
problem
now this is also fine I'm not sure it
looks like every move is winning for
white but certainly you need to have
some kind of accuracy going Queen f6 we
Nev six now we can play play look f1
cannot take g5 with the night because of
Queen f2 so need to injustice move yeah
this should be six just take everything
Knight takes rook takes Queen f7 rook f
six wins the Queen okay look I
three-carat complete completely
destroyed straw in flex flex position
here yeah this look like very bad
opening result white having a huge huge
center and black at the problem with the
skin position all the time back sorry
for the slight jump in in the game we
are on move each of the next game I
needed to pass quickly because I got a
call and another five minute game let's
check briefly cannot really determine
the opponent some someone with that with
the Dutch flag and we've got a really a
really strange position coming from some
Queens pawn opening where white has
pushed quick h4 and black has some sort
of double fianchetto going but with lots
of porn moves and the White has a very
very weird position to recon age too so
on this should be a very good position
for black yeah well from my experience
of watching Nakamura's blitz games um I
have never actually witnessed someone
beating him and in this kind of jungle
possessed positions where everything's
untidy and and weird it's really good at
this it's really a complicated and down
unconventional positions if he if he
loses it it's in dry somewhat dry
positional um play of course um it
doesn't happen too often but with this
kind of Chester you probably never win
yeah black is is clearly better just
it's cut everything in play just the
King on the eight needs to cancel at
some point if you can cancel ya think
you can doesn't didn't you to require
the King now yeah after Queen move black
and numb yeah I thought you would take
and before because you're also better on
on the queenside this is of course good
for black kid no question is got a big
space advantage and ever if everything
else fails you can ya get the night to
f6 and win this h5 pawn you can always
get this pawn it's not the best maybe
but it's possible just maneuver them the
bishop to f7 and get spawn white has
some no way to to improve his position
this is the problem
like them besides this idea of attacking
the pawn which isn't the best really you
can do what Nakamura is preparing just
preparing for F form opening up the the
Kings side and you have all the time in
the world can play 94 first if you want
and yeah get the king in the corner it's
a can why this down to two minutes yeah
if I've also interesting yes d for the
term or what is this position now with F
for coming look Sam very good for black
III is the idea yep just just III effect
or look f2 yeah this is an invasion on
the the first rank now maybe takes out
Queenie to where you can get this look
out for the moment but what about Queen
f7 Queen have six something and okay
yeah Wow wes is root going now yeah this
is the cool the group doesn't have a
move yeah like I'm were up for hip later
played too quickly but was it was a pro
just winning for black pick advantage at
least and now I don't really see a move
but what should you do yeah do you can
now you can play that but just look f2
and resins get so it's an exchange Joe
but don't do the activity white wins
pawns just a 67 to h6 take both and stop
the Jeep or now with the route g6 rook
g4 no and take g3 yeah white why player
will manage 30 seconds 40 seconds is
enough yeah this was just a sport when I
mean just me he just spent the move a
one-minute up to this this point and and
don't it it can it can lead to disaster
once in a while if you um if you play
too quickly
yeah and now this route cat's nose grab
just um just down bad luck am yeah I
just thought I just saw that he
disconnected but we got some pretty a
pretty cool games something remember the
mate with the light that all those those
pieces against the Queen yeah quite
funny yeah thanks for watching